bom minha apresentação hoje vai ser
sobre essas três coisas inovação
tecnologia e as mulheres é bem cômico
que eu dessa palestra que na usp quando
a gente pensa inovação dentro da
academia gente pensa em número de papers
em quem está produzindo tudo isso
inovação tecnologia seria o catalisador
de tudo isso a gente vive o momento
exponencial porque a tecnologia está aí
e aí a minha pergunta é onde estão todas
as mulheres que são maioria no ensino
superior que estudam em média mais tempo
mas que quando a gente vai falar de
tecnologia e inovação elas são uma
minoria esmagadora esmagadora
porque quando eu pergunto pra vocês
quantos de vocês se consideram mulheres
na tecnologia a gente tem medo a gente
tem medo de levantar a mão e falar que a
gente sabe de tecnologia porque a gente
sabe que alguém vai falar que isso não é
coisa de menina
eu como cientista da computação no gol
será uma mulher da tecnologia não é só
estudantes acadêmicos e eu tenho uma
notícia pra vocês todas vocês mulheres
na tecnologia hoje todo mundo da
tecnologia
você está com o celular que tem um
processamento maior do que aquele que
levou um foguete para até pra lua
você é da tecnologia você sabe lidar com
esse com esse celular
então não tem mais essa tá e mulheres
vocês todas as mulheres a tecnologia
eu vou contar um pouquinho de como eu
vim parar aqui tá aí pra mim é bem
comigo está fazendo esse teste aqui na
usp
quem me levou a chegar aqui foi esse
cara aqui porque ele estava código cobol
pelo telefone pra quem não sabe o que é
isso eu vou tentar explicar e se eu
tivesse que explicar eu ia voltar
criança de seis anos que era eu quando
escutava de tóquio em cobol
pra mim era só uma língua alienígena que
resolvia problemas e todo mundo amava
meu pai
todo mundo falava que ele era o máximo
que ele resolver qualquer problema ele
literalmente pra mim fazer a parte de um
clã de pessoas que dominavam a língua
que eu tinha que fazer parte desse clã é
muito legal trabalhar com tecnologia
incrível não tinha nenhuma distinção de
gênero
até que eu cheguei aqui na usp e essa
foi a situação eu cheguei aqui no dia 8
de março de 2010 olha que cônico dia da
mulher dia internacional da mulher
eram 10 e 35 e eu entrei na minha
primeira aula de algoritmos introdução
ao grito nem sabia o que era algoritmos
quem sabe o que havia ali sentei comecei
a assistir aula
e aí quando eu vi que eu não estava
entendendo luvas eu pensei preciso
descolar um caderno olhar minha voz eu
falei ok vou achar o caderno vou pegar
de uma menina que a letra melhor é
melhor e foi quando me dei conta que eu
era a única menina que tava naquela sala
de aula
aí o mundo não parou mais
porque eu cheguei casa achando que eu
era a única azarada do planeta terra que
tinha dado sorte azar no caso de itá no
único lugar que só tinha eu de menina
não é possível que aquilo era verdade
e aí eu fui pesquisar e achei essa foto
pessoal que também é que da usp do
instituto de matemática e estatística
a primeira turma de ciência da
computação eu deu uma ajudinha pra vocês
e circulei todas as meninas com bolinhas
brancas e aí a minha cabeça de um nó
como é que pode 40 anos depois quando
achava que podia ser quem eu quisesse
a gente passou de 70 por cento de
mulheres para três pontos 7 por cento
na minha cabeça não fez o menor sentido
e foi assim que tudo começou
do alto dos meus 18 anos o meu primeiro
empreendimento maravilhoso foi um blog
olha o maravilhoso
eu escrevia tudo que estava encontrando
tudo que eu queria que as pessoas vissem
sobre as mulheres sobre as inovações que
estão fazendo sobre sobretudo pela
tinham feito ele crescer um pouquinho o
agente tem uma comunidade em torno dele
e eu me orgulho muito de falar que eu
sou fundador da mulher da computação
mas hoje é muito mais do que só um blog
é uma comunidade inteira que dá voz a
essas mulheres que estudou passado vive
o presente e torce por um futuro em que
ele não precise mais existe onde eu
possa só falar de tecnologia e inovação
sem ter que fazer distinção de gênero
eu tenho bastante nessa jornada é um
pouco isso que eu quero contar pra vocês
o presente ele não é tão bacana minha
afinal essa é a foto tinha daquele
incensado na formatura sabe que tem o
nome de todo mundo e aí tinha só um nome
de uma menina quer o meu três pontos 7
por cento na melhor universidade do país
onde a gente produzir inovação e
tecnologia e eu só tinha uma mulher
capaz de fazer isso pra mim estava tudo
muito errado e esse é o retrato do
presente está tudo muito errado e aí
você acha que melhorou
eu falei 'não hora que eu vou falar no
tédio tem que ver se não mudou
passaram já há cinco anos eu acho que
mudou mudou coisa nenhuma pessoal
no último vestibular da fuvest a gente
teve 29 meninas ocupando tas engenharias
relacionados à tecnologia napoli 10%
e aí você olha e fala melhorou camilla
de 3.7 por cento para 10 por cento
não porque esse é o número de entrada
se se eu contar que eu tenho 79 por
cento de certeza feminina logo no
primeiro ano esse número vai chegar
rapidinho nos três pontos 7 ea gente não
pode continuar deixando isso acontecer o
que fez a gente chegar nessa situação
que a gente se encontra hoje nesse
presente ó maravilhoso onde as meninas
não estão representadas
a gente cria até hoje as meninas
diferente a gente da bonequinha e fala
que ela tem que ser mãe que ela tem que
brincar de cozinha
a professora enquanto a gente dá para os
meninos
o foguete ele pode sonhar em ser
astronauta o computador fica na sala no
quarto dele e ele pode trabalhar e que
jogar o que ele quiser a gente crie o
estereótipo de que todas as pessoas
tecnologia tem que ter o cruzeiro
barbudos e antissocial e trabalhar
dentro de um quadradinho tecnologia não
é mais isso
nos anos 80 a gente carregosa
estereótipo a gente tinha grandes
servidores da ibm a gente tinha esse
perfil
hoje em dia a tecnologia é tudo
hoje a tecnologia não tem estereótipo
nos anos 80 a gente viu assim versão
acontecer muito das drasticamente sabe
aquela foto de 1981 até 84 era verdade
depois disso inversão total ea gente
ainda tá descendo e muita gente coloca a
culpa na época porque foi a apple que
colocou o computador à disposição a
disposição do doméstico ante o
computador era só para a ciência ele
estava no centro dos centros acadêmicos
onde se fazia a ciência
aí veio é bom e fez um computador
doméstico e aí ele virou brinquedo do
menino
se você olhar qualquer é de que qualquer
comercial da apple dá tristeza é sempre
o menininho que quer ser astronauta ele
precisa de computador e sempre tem uma
doação no meio do caminho onde ele usou
o computador da menina que está
assistindo ao lado dele e com cliques só
ele quase explode computador da menina
foi assim que a gente construiu o
estereótipo pessoal e não baseado na
verdade
por fim as meninas são criadas para
serem boas em tudo a gente não pode
fracassar a gente tem que ser um bom
partido
se a gente não fizer tudo direitinho a
sociedade não vai pra frente e com
tecnologia é muito difícil você fazer
tudo certo
a inovação se nunca ninguém esteve ali
com a sua obrigação de acertar nenhuma
nenhuma mas nós enquanto gênero
construído feminino a gente tem muita
obrigação de acertar e aí a gente se
sente mal d
da inovação e tecnologia a gente tem que
ficar muito atenta para não se votar
nessa nova sociedade
outro problema enorme é que faltaram
exemplos
alguém sabe que a primeira programadora
primeiro ser humano considerado
programador era uma mulher era uma
matemática da aristocracia ninguém nunca
mais falou nada love agora nuno alan
turing em todo mundo fala tem até filme
de hollywood que eu preciso destruir o
sonho de vocês pessoal mas no black e
park que foi onde aconteceu toda aquela
história toda quebra do enigma 70% das
trabalhadoras eram mulheres
por uma simples razão física
não dá para o mesmo ser humano está em
dois lugares diferentes e os homens
estavam lutando na guerra é lógica
pessoal quem feitas base da tecnologia
quem fez as bases da computação da
internet foram as mulheres e elas foram
completamente apagadas
outro exemplo incrível r lama era ao
mesmo tempo atriz de hollywood e
alimentou iphae maravilhoso e ninguém
conte a história dela e é maravilhosa
que a novela de sua mulher fez romper
todo mundo fala em buggy
quem inventou foi ela todo mundo fala em
cobol e aí eu tive que tirar o posto do
meu pai de influenciador de eu estar
aqui hoje porque foi ela que se ela não
tivesse tentado roubar o meu pai não ia
saber programar em cobol eu não ia tá
aqui então foi ela que me trouxe aqui
ninguém contou a história dela
essa mulher é a stefhany se vivo
ela teve que mudar de nome ela fez a
primeira softwarehouse remota isso nos
anos 60 mil bem ela trocava telegrama
entre as programadoras para chegar num
consenso de software de uma
especificação ela fez software da boeing
o primeiro software embarcado da boeing
foi essa mulher que fez alimentou o
termo fila em ninguém conta a história
dela é bom pra não falar que eu sou
pessimista
destruir o sonho de vocês eu queria
falar um pouco sobre o futuro e falar
que eu acho que tem solução
se a gente trabalhar com essas meninas
com essas meninas
a gente pode inspirar uma geração
inteira
se a gente começar a mostrar para elas
tecnologia como meio e não como fim
elas vão se apaixonar tanto quanto eu me
apaixonei e qualquer um de vocês se
apaixonaria tecnologia tivesse sido
apresentado para vocês assim quando eu
coloco na mão dessas meninas uma maneira
de resolver problemas dela traz o
problema delas pra amanhã
quem não vai se apaixonar por isso que
não vai mais inovação que não é uma
tecnologia bom pra terminar eu queria
deixar um recado e um convite pra vocês
a gente tem que respirar a próxima
geração crianças e jovens para que eles
não façam distinção de gênero para que
eles não carregam esse estereótipo de
tecnologia para que eles usem tecnologia
inovação com criatividade e não só como
um trabalho técnico mas ivo
eu tenho certeza que se a gente mostrar
tudo isso pra eles e elas
a gente vai mudar o mundo com mais
igualdade com mais educação com mais
iniciativa e eu tenho certeza que o
mundo vai mudar e eu vou fazer isso nem
que a gente tenha que fazer uma menina
por vez
obrigada
[Aplausos]